TSM are one of the biggest Esports orgs
of all time TSM cement
some limited organization in North
American League of Legends and win their
fourth North American Championship
they've won countless tournaments in
almost every major scene signed some of
the brightest stars and given us some of
the most incredible moments in Esports
history everything on the line for TSM
what a year it's been from them Empire
have come so close before but they've
fallen short and they'll do so again TSM
said trust the process the process just
won you a world championship
but things have changed I think that you
know if you don't win then it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter if you're 3-2
it doesn't matter if you're 3-1 if you
don't win it doesn't matter he made so
many players cry in recent years TSM
have been caught up in several messy
controversies made baffling competitive
decisions and left the fans wondering
what's next can TSM still rise above its
troubles or is it already too late
alright folks before we get into the
video I wanted to remind you all that we
have merch now that's right we designed
awesome clothing that you can put on
your body and you can buy it all at
shop.thescore.com all right so what's
the first thing that comes to mind when
you think of TSM maybe it's their iconic
na League of Legends roster that was
once home to huge names like doublelift
Bjergsen and dyrus Smitty forced to
flash away first flight gets given to
Doris he's gonna flash away
that's a double kill for Doris and he
survives or maybe you remember their
days in
sikko where they once had most of what
later became astralis's roster and an
aggressive push this is it the big
moment debris goes what was that oh my
God it's so big head shot to follow-up
as well maybe you're a newer fan who
fell in love with Subrosa and Wardell
invalorant surprise are they he hits the
headshots he'll be fine there's one
flash comes through and drone just
swings in for the support or you're a
hardcore bolo Stan vertical though if he
just comes in right now no the timing
vertical
maybe you follow leffen in melee Armada
has no Shields
[Applause]
or imperial Hal in Apex Hal gets one
number one whatever game you prefer TSM
has probably fielded some pretty
incredible players in it the orgs impact
on Competitive Gaming simply cannot be
overstated and as you might expect for
an org that was that big for so long
tsm's fan base has expanded to truly
terrifying proportions
and the crowd reacts with the
three-letter chant known and loved in
Esports how long have you been a TSA fan
well that just about sums up TSM fans
TSM fans are so dedicated in part
because the team was one of the first to
do content the way we think about it
today they have their league players
recording Vlogs doing House tours and
filming documentaries long before that
was the norm basically setting the
standard for modern Esports content TSM
was one of the first orgs to bring the
fans closer to the players making those
players beloved for more than just their
in-game skills some fans stuck around
for the games some for the personalities
but many have found something special in
TSM as a whole TSM has a habit of
surprising you as a fan you know when
you least expect it sometimes sometimes
in a good way sometimes in a bad way and
speaking of bad over the past few years
TSM has experienced a pretty massive
fall from glory and look every Esports
org runs into problems at some point
whether it's team performances internal
conflicts or personal player issues that
get in the way of competing
unfortunately for TSM though it wasn't
any one of those things
it was all of them
back in 2016 TSM was unquestionably the
best League of Legends team in N A
internationally though they struggled
that year TSM were knocked out of Worlds
after a very close group stage
then this is going down
team solomage their hopes their dreams
they're done Royal headphones to Chicago
tsm's star ADC doublelift took a break
the next spring to stream and the team
floundered domestically until his return
in the summer they won the summer split
finals but got booted in groups at
Worlds once again Agony in defeat here
for TSM how again out in group stages in
World 2017. last year same roster high
expectations not able to get past groups
and things really didn't get better from
there TSM didn't even make worlds in
2018 and 2019. the team struggled to
find a roster that gel cycling through
junglers in particular as they shuffled
various high-profile players in and out
of the team I think part of the problem
is because TSM and the fans have such a
high expectation based on previous
pedigree there's a real there's almost
like a sense of panic sometimes at least
that's what it feels like on the outside
when things don't go well or another
year starts off with new players and you
know things aren't doing too well
there's this sort of panic to like
change things up there was a glimmer of
hope for TSM after both doublelift and
former support biofrost returned to the
team in 2020. they actually made it to
Worlds as Nas first seed only to fail
miserably and go 0 and 6 in groups
of Baron and that's going to get them
the victory this game doublelift left
the pro team but stayed on as a content
creator while Bjergsen became the coach
ahead of the 2021 season but this was
when things took a turn for the weird
Once Upon a Time tsm's founder and CEO
Andy Reginald din was the very first mid
laner for the orgs league team and as
someone who knew the ins and outs of the
game even after he retired from Pro play
Reggie has always taken a very Hands-On
approach to the development of tsm's
league roster far more so than you'd
expect from the owner of a huge org
years after he stepped away from the
main roster Reggie would frequently act
as a coach overriding the staff if he
was unhappy with their performance when
I left there was a hole like shock
calling void where I was missing I
started trying to develop the players as
a shock collar and I started recruiting
better mechanical players but as it
turned out Reggie's Relentless pursuit
of League wins allegedly went beyond
taking an active hand in Recruitment and
Player Development in November of 2021
doublelift publicly accused TSM CEO of
systemic harassment and bullying of the
orgs players throughout the years so I
was say that he made a lot of players
cry you would be very [__] surprised
at how many of maybe your your favorite
familiar faces in LCS
legit mental breakdown because of how
badly
they've been getting berated how badly
they were just getting verbally
assaulted Reggie responded to the
accusations by throwing some heat back
onto doublelift for being indecisive and
flip-flopping on his decision to
continue playing for the main roster
tons of other people chimed in from both
sides with some defending Reggie's
conduct and some confirming doublelift
story old clips that seemed to support
what doublelift was saying resurfaced
I'm playing a game dude
all right I'm sorry for being rude then
all right
sorry
are you arguing just to argue with me no
it feels like like you're just trying to
put it on Turtle no I'm not putting it
all in here at all no you are putting it
all in turtle
okay yeah okay oh yeah you are yeah he's
like a bully who gets away with being a
bad person because he's powerful because
people are afraid to stand up to him and
that's what I'm sick of following
doublelifts claims Riot games launched
an investigation into Reggie in the sort
of work culture he was fostering at TSM
at the same time that TSM ran their own
internal investigation I found the guy
who's actually investigating the the
investigator himself this is the guy
that is actually investigating rumors
about Reggie's aggressive approach to
his players have been circulating for
years but with the investigations
underway as more information and
allegations surfaced regarding an
apparently toxic workplace it seemed
like these rumors might actually be true
of course probably not everything he
says he's like you know
completely correct but
um
there's a lot of things Point into this
direction and it didn't help that long
before the public spectacle around
Reddy's professional conduct broke out
tsm's Flagship League team was already
severely underperforming and continued
to do so in the months after TSM were
also criticized for the choices they
made with their 2022 roster I don't know
why it happened but I would wonder how
much of a faxer the fact that the entire
organization is owned by somebody who
interferes a lot in particularly roster
moves who can only see the game from a
mid lane perspective this guy's not a
jungler he's not a Top Lane it's not 80k
it's not a support like this guy sees
what's best for a season 2 mid laner and
I wonder how much that kind of guy
having veto
um
has impacted these decisions that are
just misplaced they're just misplaced
they don't they betray a lack of a
complete understanding of the game and
off the rift The Bullying accusations
continued to affect Reginald's
reputation tsm's own investigation found
no unlawful conduct within Reggie's
Behavior but recommended he undergo
executive leadership and culture
building training as well as establish
an Anonymous hotline for employees who
wish to submit complaints meanwhile Riot
find TSM seventy five thousand dollars
put Reggie on a two-year probation and
appointed a monitor who could keep an
eye on TSM and its players retinol did
its own investigation on TSM so he
investigated himself and surprisingly he
found out that nothing was wrong with
TSM by hiring a private investigator to
investigate himself
wow self-report or the Obama medal but
then the LCS came in and said you're
such a [__] clown and they did it
themselves and they found that he was
um he was he was with people they need
to bring all of the film crew into the
sensitivity training and executive
training and and film Andy
doing that [__] that's [__] content
he's gonna be fist fighting the
instructor on day one as much as it
sucks for the fans I think any decent
fan will be glad
um ultimately that this stuff
sees a light of day and this stuff is
looked into whenever and wherever it
happens 2022 ended pretty badly for TSM
and few fans have a lot of Hope for
their 2023 roster obviously the
performance and the allegations against
Reggie are a massive important part of
the narrative surrounding the org but
tsm's troubles don't end there as if
claims of Reggie's questionable
leadership weren't bad enough the org's
disastrous partnership with the now
bankrupt cryptocurrency company FTX put
a negative Spotlight on TSM when the
crypto exchange went under there was 6
billion in withdrawals within 72 hours
and they locked people out of cashing
out so what does that mean for TSM how
it's going to cash his paycheck next
month and that shit's gonna bounce yes
everyone knows FTX got [__] filed for
bankruptcy what do you want me to do
[__] go in their office be like what
the [__] you guys doing like I have
nothing to do with it
I don't understand and of course it's
not like all their other teams are
popping off either tsm's valorant team
spent most of the Year losing matches
that could have qualified them for the
VCT circuit their Apex team has started
to fall off a little and their DOTA
roster which allegedly only existed
because of the ill-fated FTX sponsorship
bombed out of the international without
a single Series win but for some reason
the faithful are still holding out hope
I think everybody knows me as the type
of person that really likes to to see
the success out of players in in
organizations and I'm still waiting for
the comeback for sandals and of TSM and
we had to ask well
why why is it that fans still chant TSM
at tournaments TSM aren't even attending
[Applause]
are brought into it when you enter this
Arena and you hear the cheers the cheers
the people online all the fans across
the world is it the success and the
personalities of the players on tsm's
Siege team oh
Bland
[Music]
is it the Unapologetic anti-heroism of
players like leffen and Imperial Hal
okay where are we going next Mac let me
know if it goes no exactly you don't
know that's why you listen to me or is
it perhaps loyalty from a bygone era
when TSM was the only team trying to
turn their players into personalities
but with TSM there's definitely a sort
of
um
a grim reward I feel like from uh from
seeing their highs and lows and
definitely been a bit more of a low in
the past couple of years for sure you
know
can't get any worse look at the end of
the day it's impossible to say what
keeps TSM fans hooked through thick and
thin but we can say for sure that those
fans are hoping TSM can move past all
their recent mistakes that they're
struggling teams and players can catch
up to their more successful org mates
and regain at least a portion of their
former glory until that day comes though
they remain dedicated because somehow
through all the disasters the orc has
gone through the fans are still here and
they keep chanting
foreign
than random TSM fan yeah for sure I've
seen his cat
's cat he was like he was like my cat's
in the room and I was like can you show
it to me and he was like sure bud and he
showed me his cat so I'm more of a I'm
definitely more of a Bjergsen friend
than most TSM fans I think